[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video I just wanted to briefly
update you all with some news that I
heard circulating around regarding the
third installment of the fantastic beast
films as some of you might already know
there are meant to be five fantastic
piece films in total but of course all
we've gotten so far was fantastic beasts
and where to find them in 2016 and
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald in 2018 the first film took
place in 1926 the second in 1927 and I'm
assuming that the last will take place
in 1945 when Grindelwald and Dumbledore
will presumably have their long-awaited
final battle this gives us an 18-year
gap that we would need to fill between
the third and fourth installments
originally these films were meant to
follow suit with the first two coming
out every two years following the same
pattern we would have gotten the third
installment in November of this year
then November of 2022 and lastly
November of 2024 however things clearly
didn't go exactly according to plan and
they're behind schedule it has been
expressed publicly that because of how
the first two films were received Warner
Brothers have decided to put an even
greater deal of effort into all the
films to come one news site said the
following negative reviews and weak
box-office receipts of the whole series
was something which Warner Brothers
noticed quite suddenly raising serious
concerns about their plans to launch
five series of spin-offs Warner Brothers
has now shown a great deal of confidence
in giving the third series with a great
deal of effort not to replicate the fate
of the previous films for now what we
know is this the third sequel portion is
meant to be released in November of 2021
it was initially meant to hit films this
year as I mentioned earlier but was
pushed back because of a change in the
script I don't know about you guys but
I'd much prefer that they take longer to
produce quality movies rather than
spouting them off as quickly as possible
this new approach they're taking is a
good one it son telling how Cove it will
affect this release date but given that
the film was already pushed back an
entire year I think that it gave them
plenty of opportunity to fill in some of
the gaps
actor Dan Fogler who plays jacob has
publicly expressed that the third movie
will be more significant than the first
two movies combined
which is exciting they seem to be taking
their time so that they can give us a
quality product Rowling herself as
expressed that she now has an incredible
vision of where she wants to go with the
series and has already finalized the
revised screenplay there are quite a lot
of rumors floating around about some of
the characters that we'll see in the
films most notably Hagrid and Tom Riddle
who would have been on the hogwarts
grounds during the years the films were
set Tom Riddle starts of Hogwarts in the
year 1938 and Hagrid in the year 1940
which fits the time frame if Warner
Brothers and Rowling are hoping to
re-inject some of the magic back into
the films then this would be a great
approach I'm definitely not against the
reintroduction of characters that we
know and love and was pleasantly
surprised to see young dumb model in the
films while I've enjoyed the film so far
I don't think they hit the nail on the
head quite as the Harry Potter films did
so I'm excited to see what this extra
attention means for the film's moving
forward what do you guys think what are
you hoping to see in the upcoming
fantastic beast films let us know down
in the comments section below until next
time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]